- Welcome back.
Sometimes on this show,
a theme will come up in our interviews,
a running topic that
emerges over and over again.
Somehow last season ghost
stories became a running theme
which is terrifying to me,
cuz not really into that.
And here's a mash up of some of the best.
I heard that you had a scary ghost story.
- I do I do.
- I love anything that's like paranormal
and weird and unexplained.
- You're originally from
New Hampshire, right?
- I am.
- Is anything haunted where
you're from everything.
- Every thing, every single thing.
- I'm the first one to say that
what I do is absolutely crazy.
How can someone communicate
with someone that has died?
- People have died everywhere.
If they're a ghost.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- They're gonna be kind of around.
- Oh, come on. I can't, I can't.
- I got you Kelly.
- Oh my God.
(crowd cheering)
- True or false.
There are ghosts in the white house.
- True.
- Never going
- True and listen, Kelly, you
would've liked these ghosts
cuz they were very musical.
They were musical and came with no harm.
They were kind, friendly,
compassionate ghosts.
So Barbara and I were going to sleep,
our rooms were right next to each other
and it was in college when
people would call late.
So our phone rang and I woke up
and all of a sudden we
heard 1920s piano music
coming out of our fireplace.
And I was like, surely that's
like the cat or something.
You know, we had to pretend.
But it was the middle of the night.
And you could feel the
music outta the fireplace.
And I know we tried to talk
ourselves out of it too.
Like I can see you.
What do you think?
- What I think is,
I would've immediately
exited the premises.
Oh my God.
Is it true that you have
a new passion in life?
Are you obsessed with ghosts?
I hear you are.
- It's not really a new passion.
- Okay. We are just finding out.
- You're just kind of like finding out.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- Yeah. I feel like I have,
I've accepted the fact
that like I see things
and I hear things and
- [Kelly] Wait do you really,
you've had like experiences?
- Yeah, a lot of them, a
lot of them over the years,
like even as a child growing
up, like I remember being,
like getting ready for school
when I was eight years old.
And there was you know those ducks.
That like, is like the duck
thing that you pull to toy.
- Yeah.
- There was one of those
on the dining room table,
and I started walking
and it just started
like going alongside me.
And I was like interesting,
and I kind of shut it down for a while
because like it's scary.
But I recently was like,
no, this is like a gift
and like something that
I have ability to do.
So I'm gonna lean into it.
And I recently did my first like
real paranormal investigation
with equipment and everything.
- What equipment, like
what kind of equipment?
- There's a lot, so much
on the market genuinely.
- What?
- But like my favorite thing
is called a spirit box.
- Okay. If you were a ghost
do you think you'd wanna,
I would follow people.
I'd just be nosy.
- And I was little, my
best friend and Pia.
She was there obviously.
And we were about four and six
and we were taking a bath
in the bathtub playing
and a shirt flew in, arms outstretched.
Pia, you know this, wherever Pia is.
arms outstretched, hovered
over the little tub
and then it fell in.
And whatever you're four
and six it's not that scary.
But when I
- What? That is scary at four and six.
- But not when you are little.
you're like, I don't know.
Or maybe we weren't that bright..
- Or maybe you were just,
may be you were just like,
is that supposed to happen?
Wait, oh my gosh.
- I think we weren't there.
I'm I'm looking back.
I'm scared now
- When I was probably about
seven or eight years old,
we lived in a house here
and all these kind of
weird things would go on
and they would be kind of
innocuous in the beginning
like little taps on the windows
in the middle of the night
when there was nothing
near the window to tap it.
So you just kind of hear a click.
And then I was in the bathtub
and my mom's bathtub
and she was bathing me
and I looked up and there
was no air or anything.
And there was a chandelier by the bathtub,
a little boat and it was just going
left to right to left
to right outta nowhere.
And then it just stopped the
minute that I noticed it.
And then.
- [Kelly] Did you mom see it?
- Weird stuff kept happening.
Yeah.
- [Kelly] Did your mom see it?
- Yeah my mom saw it.
- I would've grabbed you and run.
- In, yeah, literally.